[APPLAUSE]
HAROLD MABERN: Thank you.
This is going to be a
short enjoy, you guys,
because we have to be
through at 25 after,
so we have to short [INAUDIBLE].
This first composition
is a dedication
to the late great
John William Coltrane.
We affectionately
call him the Chief.
This is the Chief.
[JAZZ MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
HAROLD MABERN: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for coming out, and
you're very fortunate because,
just so you know, this music
was created in this country.
So you're very fortunate.
However, sometimes it's more
appreciated all over the world,
but it was created here.
Now here's a song.
The title is funny,
but it was dedicated
to probably the greatest
musicians that ever played,
Art Blakely and the
Jazz Messengers.
The title is called "Bobby,
Benny, Jymie, Lee Bu."
[MUSIC HAROLD MABERN, "BOBBY,
BENNY, JYMIE, LEE, BU"]
[APPLAUSE]
HAROLD MABERN:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
"Bobby, Benny, Jymie,
Lee, Bu--" that's
Bobby Timmons, Benny Golson,
Jymie Merritt, Lee Morgan,
Art Blakey Buhaina.
Thank you so much,
and we're going
to close with the title
theme from the album which
is "Afro Blue."
Unfortunately, Mr. Gregory
Porter couldn't be her to sing,
but we have Mr.
Kurt Elling here.
So we we're going to
give you a short version
of the title from the new CD.
[MUSIC HAROLD MABERN AND KURT
ELLING, "AFRO BLUE"]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: I'd like
to introduce our vocalist
today who's going to join us
for the interview as well.
He was born in Chicago.
He grew up in
Rockford, Illinois.
He's one of the world's
foremost jazz vocalists.
He has one the Critics Poll
in "DownBeat" magazine.
He had a run of 14
consecutive years,
was named male
singer of the year
eight times during that span.
He, in addition to all of those
awards, won a Grammy in 2009,
and actually every album
that he's ever made
has been nominated for a Grammy.
He has his own album
that was released
last week on the Concord label
it's called "Passion World."
Please welcome Kurt Elling.
[APPLAUSE]
KURT ELLING: Hello, sir.
HAROLD MABERN:
Everything all right?
MALE SPEAKER: Don't sit on that.
KURT ELLING: Yeah.
HAROLD MABERN: Yeah, right.
MALE SPEAKER: All
right, so, Harold, I'd
love to talk to you a bit about
just the topic of education
and learning.
I think your background
is so interesting,
coming from Memphis.
You're considered a
self-taught pianist,
but you also have made so many
contributions at the college
level over the years
at William Paterson,
and I know you've worked with
Stanford as well as Harvard
this year.
But tell me a little bit about
your experience growing up
in Memphis.
I know you transferred
into Manassas.
How did that happen?
HAROLD MABERN: Well, long story
short, I group up in Memphis,
Tennessee and graduated from
a school that's music program
was started by the late
great Jimmie Lunceford back
in the early '40s, late '30s.
And when I transferred
to Manassas,
I didn't choose music.
It sounds corny, but it
chose me because when
people were studying Chopin
etudes-- no shame in my game,
as BB King talked about.
I was chopping and picking
and pulling cotton.
So one day I heard a little girl
play a song on all the black
keys called, "I Stuck my
Dolly-- D-O-L-L-Y-- in the Mud,"
and that's the first thing
I learned. (HUMMING SONG)
So when I got to Frank Strozier,
one of my closest friends,
told me, why don't you come
to Manassas High School?
And I transferred from
Douglas to Manassas,
of my classmates were Booker
Little, George Coleman, Frank
Storzier, Charles Lord,
Hank Crawford, Lewis Smith.
Isaac Hayes was later.
And we were taught by a
man named Matthew Garrett,
and he had a daughter.
Her name was Denise Gary,
who's now Dee Dee Bridgewater.
Dee Dee Bridgewater's father
was our band director.
So anyway, I knew three songs.
1951 is when I started.
And when I moved
to Chicago I've met
Spike Lee's father, Bill Lee.
Bill Lee, one of the
greatest all-around
geniuses that ever
lived, but he's always
been anti-amplification,
and so he
wasn't born with a big sound.
But when I went to
Chicago-- that's
one the greatest
cities in the world.
That's how I learned how
to conceptualize music.
Then, when I moved
to New York, I
had a better
understanding about it.
And as I said, the first
night in New York City,
Cannonball introduced me
to Harry "Sweets" Edison.
And old timers
then, they assumed
if you're a musician--
Kurt can tell you--
you get on the [INAUDIBLE],
you know everything.
So Sweet says to me,
you want to play?
I said, yeah.
So he said, "Habit,"
eight by interjection.
I said, well what
the heck is "Habit"?
I knew how play eight
by interjection.
The song was "Getting
to be a Habit with You."
never played it before.
I fumbled.
Second chorus I had it.
He said, you got the get.
He took me right
back to Chicago.
I made $250 a week
at the Blue Note.
Now in case you young people
don't know how money that was,
in 1959 I had $5,000.
$2,500 in this shoe,
and $2,500 in that shoe.
Why?
Because that was so long ago,
you know these Ziploc bags
that you take for granted?
They weren't on the market then.
They were being tested.
And to show you how
much money that was,
I'm going to fast forward
because once I get to talking,
you can't stop me.
The Four Seasons hotel which
starts at $750 a night,
was $50 a week.
The legendary
[INAUDIBLE] was 99 cents.
That was the cover charge.
So anyway, fast forward, and
I was blessed because I came.
I was hustling.
I promoted myself,
and I got a call
to teach at William
Paterson in 1981,
and I've been there
since that time.
And I must say, this gentleman
and the young man on the drums,
two of my prized
students, and I'm still
teaching, because when
you teach, you learn.
And I'm going to turn it
over to somebody else.
MALE SPEAKER:
Thank you for that.
Just on the topic of
learning, I guess,
Harold was Eric's teacher.
He was my teacher, and
one of the ideas in jazz
and just kind of the way
that the music evolves,
it's if you hear
it, you can have it.
It's this idea that
everything's right there for you
to learn and try to
incorporate into your playing,
and people just added ideas.
They find a way to
make them their own.
And over time, you get some
really unique contributions
to the music.
And it sounds a
little bit like-- I
guess I'll make an internet
analogy-- there's open source
code.
There's things like Wikipedia
with a lot of people
just kind of
collectively contributing
in similar way as music.
So tell me a little bit
about your experience
working with Eric.
I know you guys
met when Eric was
in school at William
Paterson, but you've
gone on to work a lot together.
HAROLD MABERN: Yeah, he
left Indiana University
and professor Dave
Baker told Rufus Reid.
Rufus was a professor there.
Then we got a young
tenor player coming,
and we'd like for you
to see what you can do.
So Rufus assigned
him to my class.
And I always tell
the students, you
should always have a
tape recorder with you
and some manuscript paper.
So Eric came in.
I had him play
"Embraceable You."
He'd never played it before in
his life, and what he played,
believe me, was a
complete masterpiece.
And unfortunately, I
didn't follow my own advice
because I couldn't document it.
And he was playing like Dexter
Gordon there, which is great.
And I knew then, I
said to myself, well,
this is an A student, really.
And I told him three things.
I said learn all your
standards in all the keys,
and go see George
Coleman, and he did.
He took two lessons,
and the rest
is history, as they say--
very smart young man.
And please don't try to pay
me, because I'm serious.
This is one of the
smartest young man
playing any kind of music.
and he plays piano--
Ravel and Debussy and all.
So it's a pleasure
working with him,
and we learn from each other.
Now we've been-- how many
CDs have we done together?
On [INAUDIBLE], I'd say
we've made at least 20.
ERIC ALEXANDER: But we've
probably been on at least 70.
HAROLD MABERN: At least 70
together with other people,
so I'm going to let him talk.
And he's an expert skier.
ERIC ALEXANDER: You know, I
want to backtrack for a moment,
if that's OK.
That tune you mentioned, "I
Stuck My Dolly in the Mud?"
See, I had a
different upbringing.
We called that "Salvadore
Dali in the Mud."
HAROLD MABERN: Really?
ERIC ALEXANDER: Yeah.
HAROLD MABERN: So
you know about this?
I didn't know that.
ERIC ALEXANDER: And what am I
supposed to be addressing here,
Andrew?
Harold was-- this is
his show, so let's keep.
HAROLD MABERN:
No, it's our show.
ERIC ALEXANDER:
Well, he's certainly
the most influential
musical mentor
that I've ever encountered.
He took me, despite what
he says, from a point
where I was absolutely green,
and saw some something in there
and was always willing to
help and show me new ideas,
and he's really the primary
reason for whatever I'm
doing today or however I play.
I thank Harold every day,
at least, in my mind,
sometimes not to your face.
I do.
And it's funny; we've actually
been around each other now,
if I think about the
years since I started
working as a professional, I've
probably been next to this man
more than any other person on
the planet, including my wife,
and that probably
pisses her off.
We're always on the
road doing something.
It's really amazing.
It's like a dream come true.
I don't know what to say.
Teaching and learning in jazz
is very different from other art
forms or, in particular,
Western classical art music
because it's not as pedagogical.
Like Andrew said,
it's more about
if you can hear
it and figure out
what it is in sort of an
intuitive and personal way,
then you can make it your own.
And it just takes somebody to
continually show you things.
They don't tell you how
to do it necessarily,
but they show you
what it sounds like,
and then eventually you
start to pick it up,
and that's what he's been
doing for me for 25 years.
MALE SPEAKER: Great, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I want to talk to Kurt as well
about his new album "Passion
World."
And jazz is music that, like
Harold said before, it's
from the United States, but it
just has a tremendous appeal
globally.
These guys will tell you,
they keep a very busy touring
schedule, going to Asia and
Europe and all over the place.
And Kurt's latest album
has a very global focus.
I know people love jazz
all over the world,
but it also has influence
some of the material
that jazz musicians play
in the United States.
And also there are great
musicians everywhere,
and I think Kurt's latest
album captures a lot of that.
So what can you tell us
about how that came together?
KURT ELLING: Well, first
of all, hi, everybody.
Happy to be here.
Harold Mabern, great genius,
happy to be his side man
this evening.
It's wonderful.
I'm happy to have a
little bit of time.
It's an honor for me.
Jazz is the ultimate
syncratic art
form, which means
that any music,
any sound that it encounters,
any rhythm any tradition,
anything that it encounters
that it finds valuable,
it can adopt and transform.
And it transforms
itself, and it transforms
that which it encounters.
As Harold said, it was
born in the United States,
but it was born of so many
different countries and so many
different traditions.
It was born of the collision
of cultures, largely, but not
exclusively in New Orleans.
It grew up in Chicago,
yet more collision
of cultures-- collision
of African-- vast
over-generalization--
collision of African rhythms
with European harmonic
ideas and instrumentation.
And it continues to
seek out new ideas,
and it continues to grow in
all these different countries,
having grown up in America.
Dizzy Gillespie, back in
the day, goes down to Cuba
and moves from hard
swinging everything
to a whole new way
of thinking of music
and calls it Afro Cuban music.
And it puts a whole new gloss on
what he was about as an artist.
And these days you have
artists around the world who
have encountered jazz-- "jazz,"
quote unquote, American style--
who have encountered
it, who have fallen
in love with the great
pillar heroes of the music,
and yet have brought their own
sensibilities to the music.
So you have a whole
Scandinavian realm
of artists who sound only like
themselves, who are informed
by the American tradition but
bring their own identities
to the music and have a
signature event that's
happening up there.
You have people in France
who make beautiful gypsy
kind of sounding
jazz music, who swing
in a way that belongs to them.
You have cats now
who are working
with Indian poly-rhythms, who
are a mixture of American cats
and cats from India who are in
just moving the music forward
in ways that nobody had
thought of even 10 years ago.
And it's from the creative
juxtaposition of ideas
that a lot of the
greatest sounds happen.
So on my recording
"Passion World," since I've
been out touring not nearly
as long as Dr. Mabern here,
but I've been out for
about 20 years now,
and I go to Europe all the
time, and I go to Asia,
and I go to South
America and try
to learn wherever I go,
who are the great players.
Fans will come up afterwards,
oh, man, thank you so much.
I say, hey, who's around here?
Who can I stay
awake for tonight?
And as I've done that I've
collected certain compositions,
certain ways of
thinking about things
and certain
international heroes,
and I wanted to include them in
my own sound, in my own world,
and I wanted to feature
them in a certain kind
of a way in the United States.
So on this recording we have
Till Bronner from Germany.
We have Arturo Sandoval,
who's obviously many decades
ago now moved up from
Cuba, Richard Galliano,
incredible virtuoso
French accordion player.
As a Chicagoan, I can always
hear the accordion [INAUDIBLE]
all the Chicago cats because
of the Polish connection.
Got a beautiful
thing from Poland
from Pat Metheny,
orchestra from Germany.
So we are Americans
who encounter the world
and try to continue
learning, just
as Dr. Mabern here continues
to learn from his students.
And it's also
romantic, which is good
because you know I'm
on your team for that.
I want that to happen.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: And
bringing it back
to "Afro Blue" for a
moment, just, of course,
this is improvised music,
and there's a structure,
but what these guys are doing is
basically composing on the fly.
And I heard a story
about one of the tunes
that you did with Harold that
wasn't planned to happen.
KURT ELLING: Yes, we
had several things,
and I was so proud to get
the call in the first place,
to jump in on a
couple of things that
are more traditional that we'll
be doing a little bit later.
But then, as I had my coat on--
this was January sometime--
HAROLD MABERN: August.
KURT ELLING: Was it August?
I thought I was
putting my coat on.
Really?
HAROLD MABERN: That's OK.
It's--
KURT ELLING: It's what
we call a schmear.
ERIC ALEXANDER: You might
have been hiding something.
KURT ELLING: Maybe I was.
I'm always hiding something,
So anyway, I was on my way out,
and Harold started to--
I heard you talking
about this other tune
that you want to do,
and I don't remember how
it wasn't going to happen
or was going to happen,
but you started playing.
HAROLD MABERN: Originally
I had Norah Jones in mind.
This is a true story, folks.
Is it on?
Originally this song is called
"You Needed Me" by Anne Murray,
and George Coleman
kind of instigated this
because he said, hey, Mabe.
My friends call me Mabe.
He said, do you ever play
that song "You Needed Me?"
And I said, yeah.
So we got to the day,
and I wanted Norah Jones,
but Paul Stache felt that
maybe, stylistically speaking,
it wouldn't be good for Norah.
So I said, OK.
So I told her.
We call him Big
Red affectionately
because of his red hair.
So I said, well, come on, Big
Red, we've got to do this song.
I said, you've got
to do Boots Randolph,
because I was
determined-- true story.
I guess you could say it
was kind of like, what,
serendipity?
Kurt had his-- he did his two
songs, thank you very much.
He was walking out the door,
so we started playing it.
He walks over to the piano.
He starts singing, (SINGING)
you took-- (SPEAKING) I said,
uh-oh, and the rest is history.
And he nailed it.
That's how that happened.
That's why I say this
music is telepathic.
You have to think.
Jazz musicians-- let
me just throw this out.
No offense to anybody--
what you don't know
is jazz musicians are some
of the smartest people
in the world outside from this.
You probably didn't--
[LAUGHTER]
No, no-- [INAUDIBLE]
speaks fluent Japanese.
Now he's starting
the Korean language,
which is totally different.
Dr. Willie Ross,
speaks seven languages.
He's been at Yale
for over 60 years.
Dr. Don Byrd had four--
you heard of Don Byrd.
He had four earned
degrees-- no honorary-- plus
he had a law degree, plus
he was an airplane pilot.
Keith Jarrett did the
"Goldberg Variations,"
so forth and so on.
I could go on.
We don't have enough time.
Josh Redman has two
degrees-- MIT and Harvard.
So what I'm saying
is to play this music
you've got to be a thinker.
You have to think fast,
quick on your feet.
And, as I said before,
not to be redundant,
it's a pleasure to have all
these great artists on my CD.
They made me look
good and sound good,
and I just want to share
that with you again.
Thanks for your support.
Now you can finish talking.
MALE SPEAKER: I think that's it.
We want to save some time
for the vocal performance,
so we can get to that
now, but thank you all.
HAROLD MABERN: All
right, let's do it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC HAROLD MABERN AND KURT
ELLING, "YOU NEEDED ME"]
[APPLAUSE]
KURT ELLING: Here's a
lovely, lovely composition.
This one was written as the
theme to a David O. Selznick
produced film in 1948-- a really
strange and unusual fantasy
film.
It was a romance, of course, but
it involved a young woman who
worked in an office, a young
man who worked in an office,
and he fell in love with
this young woman who
he kept seeing in
Central Park, and she
got strangely and kind of a
little bit of a Benjamin Button
kind of a thing.
She kept getting older
at an accelerated rate,
and she, at the same
time, was living
as though she was in a time
that was 50, 100 years earlier
and referring to
news events that
happened 50, 100 years earlier.
And it's a tragedy.
It's gotta be a tragedy,
and yet it brought out
this lovely, wonderful song.
[MUSIC HAROLD MABERN AND KURT
ELLING,"PORTRAIT OF JENNIE"]
[APPLAUSE]
KURT ELLING: Harold Mabern.
I'm an amateur, and yet--
[MUSIC HAROLD MABERN AND KURT
ELLING, "BILLIE'S BOUNCE"]
KURT ELLING: Eric Alexander.
Harold Mabern.
John Webber.
HAROLD MABERN: Kurt Elling.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: We're going to
do a quick Q&A for anybody who
has questions.
This was just an
incredible performance,
as I knew would be, so
thanks to the musicians.
But if anybody has questions,
please come up to the mic here.
HAROLD MABERN: There's no such
thing as a stupid question.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm serious, so
don't hold back now.
Speak now or forever
hold your peace.
Who's got a question about
anything-- what we do,
why we do it?
The first time I
was able to make
an album as a leader-- that's
a good question-- was in 1968,
I think, and I
signed with Prestige.
And the record producer, he
didn't have much faith in me.
He said, well, we'll
sign you, and he give me
a $100 advance,
which was an insult.
I should have given it back
to him, but I needed it,
and I wanted to do a record.
He said, I don't expect
you to sell by 500 records.
I said, OK.
So during that time,
we had "Record World."
We had the "Billboard"
and there was one other.
So I sent a letter to
40 distributors saying,
I have a new CD.
It's called "A Few
Miles from Memphis."
The first statement I got
from the record company
was 3,500 copies.
I said, uh-oh, you didn't
say I would sell but 500.
But that was something
for me because I
needed to get a product out.
And it was a good
experience for me,
but the thing I found out--
and if any musicians here,
when you go in the studio, tried
to be as prepared as you can.
When I went in, I made sure
all the notes were right,
so we didn't lose a lot of time.
Because when you're losing time,
changing notes, and doing this,
that costs the record
company a lot of money.
So that was my first venture
of doing something on my own.
The record is called "A
Few Miles From Memphis."
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Memphis--
HAROLD MABERN: I'm
sorry, say that again.
MALE SPEAKER: Here.
AUDIENCE: I'm super interested
in both blues and jazz.
[INAUDIBLE] Memphis,
how does [INAUDIBLE]?
HAROLD MABERN: Well, they
said that New Orleans
is the city of jazz.
Memphis is the
home of the blues.
You see, blues, here's
the thing about the blues.
Mr. Kurt Elling said something
that was so eloquently put,
I wish I could've recorded
it to for my own teaching.
Here's the thing; the blues
form this is the first thing you
learn when you start playing
jazz. (SINGING) I saw
my baby walking down--
(SPEAKING) [INAUDIBLE]
one, four, five.
But as you get older, you
realize it becomes the hardest.
Why?
Because you can't teach
somebody how to play the blues.
You can't do it.
I could write down some
notes, but it's not the same.
It has to come from here.
Now, Eric Alexander learned
how to play the blues
because he worked with an
organ player named you see.
So when you hit a certain
environment, in other words,
if you want to be a great
three point shooter,
you've got a practice like Larry
Bird and like Magic Johnson,
like Michael Jordan
and not Labron James.
So when we started,
we hated the blues.
We wanted to play Bebop.
But as we grew older, we
realized how important
the blues is.
See jazz comes from the blues
not the other way around.
You know what I'm saying?
When you hear the blues,
you think about BB King,
you think about Little
Milton Campbell,
you think about Joe Williams,
you think about Clarence T-Bone
Walker.
So the blues is a special part.
The great Dizzy Gillespie, the
co-progenitor of this music
said, the difference
between me and Bird-- Bird
is Charlie Parker.
He said, Byrd can play
the blues and I couldn't.
He's right.
He couldn't play the blues.
He could play a
blues lick, you see.
The blues-- like there's a
great pianist named Gene Harris.
Anybody ever hear
of Gene Harris?
Now, if I could play
the blues like him,
I could stick my chest out.
Now, he could play the blues.
And he said one time, I'm a
blues piano player with chops.
People ask me; I said,
I'm a blues piano player
that understands the
philosophy of jazz, which
means I can play the blues.
I can play the boogie
woogie, but I can also
play the old milestone.
I can also play [INAUDIBLE].
So the blues is very special.
Because all over
the world, no matter
what your nationality is,
people understand the blues
all over the world or
anything that's bluesy.
Gene Ammons, Stanley
Turrentine-- bluesy.
You see what I'm saying?
So when you can understand
the blues and play it,
you're in the right role.
I hope that answers
your question.
Anybody else?
Come on now, don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: How old were you
when you started playing music?
HAROLD MABERN: Good question.
How old was I?
As I said before, I was
15 and 1/2, 16 years old.
As I said before,
no shame in my game.
When guys were
taking Chopin etudes,
I was chopping, picking,
and pulling cotton.
BB King talked about that--
that that is the blues.
And the first thing I learned
how to play, as I said before,
is a song called "I Stuck
My Dolly-- D-O-L-L-Y--
dolly's a little baby
doll-- in the Mud."
And the reason why
I know it's true
is because I met a young
lady five years ago up
at [INAUDIBLE].
She said, Mr. Mabern, how long
have you been playing, and what
was the first-- and I told her.
She said, oh, I know that song.
She said, it's called "I
Stuck My Dolly in the Dirt."
so it's the same
song with different--
but I think it comes
from something that Ravel
that Debussy wrote.
Let me play it for you quickly.
This is the first song
that I ever played.
[MUSIC HAROLD MABERN, " I STUCK
MY DOLLY IN THE DIRT"]
So that was my introduction--
[APPLAUSE]
I never had formal
training, but see,
I believe we are all born
with some kind of gift.
It's up to you to find out and
then grab it when it comes.
Sometimes you might miss
it, so sprinkle, sprinkle.
I heard a little girl playing
that, and I went to the piano,
and learned two songs.
When I moved to Chicago
and met Spike Lee's dad,
that's when I really
got into music
because we were practicing
and playing music
12 hours a day every
day for five years.
OK, anybody else?
Speak up-- don't be shy.
MALE SPEAKER: Looks like
there's one more on the right.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for playing today.
I find it very interesting
that you're self-taught,
yet you ended up in
academia teaching
at William Paterson University.
I feel like you've seen
both sides of the coin,
being self-taught,
and you probably
see tons of students who
have a formal education.
What would you say are the
advantages and disadvantages
of each-- school learning
how to play music
and learning how to play jazz?
HAROLD MABERN:
Very good question.
Well, see, even though I've
been in the university for theta
34 years-- I taught Joe
Farnsworth, Eric Alexander,
Bill Stewart, Tyshawn Sorey, and
Alexis Cole, the young lady my
[INAUDIBLE].
See, this music comes
from what I call
the 'university of the streets.'
You don't have to go to school
to learn it.
Going to school is
just an enhancement.
You know what I mean?
I'm the proof of that.
But I've learned
how to be-- see,
jazz musicians are
very ubiquitous.
I wish I had more
time for examples.
We've heard of the
great Bill Rossi.
You know that guy that
played with the Seltzers that
don't sign autographs.
His best and closest friend
was Julian Cannonball Adderley.
You didn't know that, did you?
I wonder why.
Why would-- Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
You know who his
best friend was?
"Freddie" Dewayne Hubbard.
One of my closest friends
is Dr. Dick Barnett
who used to play with
the Knickerbockers.
I wrote a song called "Too
Late, Fall Back, Baby."
So what I'm saying,
to play this music
you don't have to go to school.
You can get all
the books you want.
It's not the same.
It comes from the street.
This is street music.
For example, we can
go outside of the box.
Other musicians can't do this.
We can.
We can play this.
[MUSIC - "FRAGILE"]
Anybody know that song?
What was that?
Sting.
You see what I'm saying?
But also, here's the thing--
we don't have a whole lot
of time-- very little.
When you get yourself involved
with jazz, even if you don't
play, if you take a course
in Jazz Appreciation,
being a jazz musician
will teach you
how to make decisions
in your real life.
It might sound
funny because you've
got to be very perceptive.
You've got to be very
ubiquitous in your thoughts
and how you make
decisions and stuff.
So every day I wake
up, I say, dear lord,
thank you for making
a jazz musician.
Because I didn't
choose it; it chose me,
as I said before,
not to be redundant.
We all are born with some
special kind of gift.
But it's up to you to
find out what it is.
And when it comes, sometimes
it might be just a quick flash.
You've got to grab it.
So I hope that
answered your question.
I thank you for coming out.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Harold.
HAROLD MABERN: I hope
we can do it again.
[APPLAUSE]